I understand the difficulty and
complexity of running the Department of
Homeland Security but it is clear to me
and to millions of Americans that this
is a crisis by Design and one that was
avoidable my staff and I engaged and
advised the Biden transition teams well
before inauguration advice from career
professionals was ignored he sworn oath
to support and defend the Constitution
of the United States since then the
American people have suffered from a
national security humanitarian and
Public Safety disaster at the Southwest
border
the house Homeland Security committee
kicking off their investigation into DHS
secretary Alejandra mayorkas over his
quote dereliction of Duty at the border
chairman Mark Greene led the hearing and
he joins us now good morning to you
Congressman good morning good morning so
I'm listening to the hearings yesterday
and you make a good point that the
president swore to defend our
Constitution which means defend the
citizens is there any is it what happens
next is there any he needs to be held
accountable how can he get away with us
yeah so I I couldn't agree more both he
and America Secretary of America you
know they swore notes to protect
Americans to protect the Constitution of
the United States and our rights and uh
they've they failed to do that um and so
what we've done is launched a
five-phased uh accountability and you
know investigation basically into
America's as americus's activities
um and phase one was the dereliction of
Duty phase where we talk about the 11
laws that he's broken uh two court
orders he's refused to obey lying to
Congress and things like that of course
the whole cause and effect of this
um is that the American people are not
safe our national security is at risk
Chad Wolfe said he's the former acting
DHS secretary he said it's clear to him
that this is a crisis by Design and
avoidable do you agree
oh I agree 100 you can look at every
decision they've made it's to open our
border as wide as possible they created
the migration crisis and you know in
this region uh people tested the system
early on saw that they could get in and
get released and so they called back
home and millions have come and for 160
different countries and now we're
hearing you know thousands of Chinese
Nationals coming across it's a it's a
travesty and it's intentional why is it
intentional I don't understand I mean
it's dangerous we can't afford to house
these individuals of course you have a
heart for people in other countries but
you can't just open your border
yeah absolutely you know and and if you
speak at that heart thing it's really uh
let's assume for a second that it's all
altruistic and they want to help but why
is the government picking where my
charity goes where tennesseans charity
goes maybe we want to take care of gold
star families or something like that so
it's it's not Freedom right but
um it's really the risk to the American
people you ask why I mean the best guess
I can give as they think folks will come
here and vote Democrat I mean I can't
think of any other
um reason Beyond just uh they're
choosing that or choosing to to use my
taxpayer dollars to give to their
charitable cause you know I feel like
ran on this moderate agenda he's going
to unify the country a lot of people
might have voted for him as a referendum
on Trump just to have change and and
some peace of mind for a little while
but then when you hear Rodney Scott talk
about how we went in and we tried to
help the transition team with the border
and they you know listened to us they
were going to follow our rules and then
the moment that the inauguration happens
everything changes every everything all
those promises go out the door
yeah I think that was one of the more
revealing things we got out of
yesterday's hearing is that they
basically shut down all information flow
from the professionals who secure our
border to secretary Marcus and that's uh
startling because just in the Senate a
few months ago mayork has admitted he
didn't even understand the core strategy
of the drug cartels to get the fentanyl
into the United States and uh Merrick
Garland had admitted he knew it but
mayorcas didn't I mean that's admitting
incompetence to the United States Senate
and it's all because he wouldn't listen
to his own people
unbelievable Congressman Mark green
thank you so much for joining us thanks
to Ansley you're welcome I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis